We'd have shootarounds
I'd go home, smoke a joint
take a nap, eat
then go to the game
I feel like this is the most dynamic plant on earth
Don't be naive to the fact that its
It's helping people
How beneficial would it be then to legalize it for the league?
Super beneficial
[laughter]
Basically everyone in this table has smoked before
I think that everyone always remembers the first time that they smoked
So I'll start with Cuttino
Do you remember your first time smoking?
What it was about?
Yeah, I just told the guys right before this
the very first time I smoked was with my business partner
The very first time I smoked was with my business partner
Um, May—it was May 7th
It was last year in Miami
He remembers the date
[laughter]
Like a child— like a—
4:58 p.m.
Yeah, you know what I'm saying?
- Nine—
- I sparked up
It was actually Blue Dream
I used to—my—
my dad used to grow weed, so I'd steal it like, fresh off the plant
- For real?
- You know what I mean?
Stems and sticks and
- seeds and all
- Smokin' it wet
Honestly, yeah, for real
I was— I was little— I was 14
Yeah, for me, man, it was, uh
it was actually when I was playing in Golden State
- We were—
- Bad influences
Which one you gonna blame?
Man, all of them
Yo, we was, uh, we were in Phoenix
and, um
we sitting in the room
and they win
So we're sittin' there and everybody is pissed off
especially because, you know, we won more games
than, you know, we won for the "We Believe" year and all that
So they just start sparking up
and they just like, "Al, you gonna hit this?"
And I'm like, "Man, I'll try it"
And I've been smokin' ever since
I was a freshman in college
Um, tried it once and
put me out. I didn't like the feeling.
Sitting there, I got queasy
I was like, "Yo"
So I know what that meant
Like, I know what it means now
Like, I was loaded
You know what I'm saying? Like
Like I know now like. I was, like, out of my mind
But I just tried it again
and I'm like
"This ain't that bad"
"Yeah, this is— this is probably going to be my lane here"
Did y'all ever play high?
I know y'all were talking about that earlier, but did y'all
I never played after smoking
But we were playing Indiana one day
like, I wasn't feeling well. I had a hamstring, a hip or something.
So I smoked and like. I wasn't gonna play originally
So we got to the arena and I'm like
Felt better
I feel— I feel good
Like, I went out there and had a great game
Yo, what numbers did you do?
I was like, 24. I'm saying, like, double-double
I was like, "Yo, this is"
like I felt great
Anybody else ever smoke and play?
Me? No
You did?
My whole life, really
For real?
From high school to college to the pros
- What was your routine?
- Um, I just found a way
Um, I'm telling on myself. I don't give a f--k now
I mean, I would— what I would do is I would do sh—
You know I mean? We'd have shootaround
I'd go home, smoke a joint, take a nap, wake up, take a shower
shower was important, shower would wake me back up,
eat and go to the game
What was the best game you remember?
All my best games, I was medicated
- For real?
- Yeah, I was— that's
Like I said, like he said, I mean, he
he felt like he couldn't play that night
You know what I mean?
And he smoked, and he went and had a great—
Like, so I just— I just knew I— as much as I could
It wasn't every single game but
in 15 years, it was a lot
You know a lot of people who smoke, but
a lot of it's behind the scenes and stuff like that
Particularly in the NBA
how many closet smokers you think there are?
S--t, I think 85% of the league. Well—
I think like, our—
Old NBA?
- Since I left
- Yes, yeah
Like, early-mid 2000s
It was a lot. It was people who you wouldn't think
- You know what I'm sayin'? Like
- Yeah, a lot of people
- the people who you'd never hang out with and would never think
- But at the same time
- You know what I'm saying?
- the GMs, coaches, presidents
like, as far as when you want to say "closet"
I mean, it goes deeper than what you think
- You know what I mean?
- Yeah, it ain't just—
Yeah, some of these people that are cracking whips on us—
- Trainers and—
- I mean, yeah
- You know what I'm saying?
- Yeah, some of the people that are cracking whips
and suspending us are smoking weed
Mostly everybody's a closet smoker
All my billionaire mentors or whatever, they all consume
They smoke like— they smoke like crazy
-So how beneficial would it be, then, to legalize it for the league?
Very
I mean, listen, super beneficial
If you have access to something
If you have information about something
you will become disciplined enough to understand
when I should take it or when I shouldn't
But when you have someone telling you cannot do something
you're going to fight that system
I don't care who you are
When we first came in the NBA
we used to get that one preseason drug test
and you could rock the whole year
When did it start going random, bro?
Going into my fifth year
Yeah
I think it had to do with some baseball steroid stuff
so we started, and they knew that marijuana was the only problem
We didn't have no steroid problems
They had a perception that
all these black athletes are out here smoking weed
So how do you pass the test then?
Nah like, I didn't, uhh, yeah, I didn't, uhh, yeah
[laughter] Some things you don't need to know about
[talking over each other in agreement]
But think about it. We rarely got in trouble too
[clears throat]
We didn't really truthfully get in trouble
I got in some trouble
[laughter]
When all the propositions were coming up to legalize it
like, people were just crazy trying to push this stuff
or did you think there was an actual chance?
No, I believed in it because like I said
I've been a longtime smoker and just
have known what it's capable of
and I think it was fear, or I mean
it's feared because of the stereotypes we have today
It's pictured as, you know, a gateway drug
or, you know, a
you know, a black thing, so to speak
And at the end of the day, like, with cannabis
like, you know, we can't go out and say that it heals anything right now
because of the FDA and stuff like that
But we have all these stories where it does
reading up on, like, how it helped kids with epilepsy
and different things like that
how it helped people deal with so many different issues
You know what I'm saying?
Even people, like, that are terminally ill with cancer and HIV
give them a better quality of life
You know, I feel like
this is the most dynamic plant on earth
because it does so many things
I played 15 years, man
Like, and made it through like, a lot of major injuries
and still was able to play at a high level
You know, and that's through most of my career
you know what I'm saying, me self-medicating
You know like, I'm the only athlete—
basketball player, to come back from
two microfracture surgeries
on each knee and play basketball, man
Like, that's medicine
I walk around to this day
Like, I've had major reconstructive surgery on my
on my left ankle
I've had my patella repaired, like
I walk around, man, and no pain
My life was on TV, man
I'm going through—
My mom dies when I'm playing in Golden State
and I played the next day
the day after my mom dies
I get divorced. You know what I mean?
I have a reality TV lifestyle
My ex-wife is with my former teammate
Like, there's a lot of s--t that would break normal people
You know what I mean?
But I'm sitting back smoking a joint
able to laugh at my life because
like, damn, this is going to be a crazy story when I get older, man
You know what I mean?
Like, all the s--t I done been through
and I didn't kill myself
or I'm not in prison?
Did you smoke when you was driving to the—?
On the way to get Derek?
[laughter]
I just— I just—
Earlier that night I had
- Earlier that night?
- Yeah
- How was training camp?
Then I was listening— I was—
I was listening to Tupac on the way over there
That boy didn't stand a chance
You feel me?
[laughter]
[inaudible]
- My man
- Did weed help you out mentally through that whole process?
Ah, that's what I'm saying
It kept me sane
I've been someone that just smoked
because I know how it made me feel
- Yeah, definitely
- But now—
Now regardless if it was against the rules for the NBA
I knew what it kept me from doing
on a mental standpoint
and how it made me feel after we played a back-to-back
You know what I mean? Heading into the playoffs
getting ready for the playoffs
Like, I just knew that, man
Man, I'm gonna hit that
My back is gonna feel better. My toe is going to feel better
My finger—I have broke all my fingers
My fingers are going to be all right
I just know like, tomorrow's going to be
you know, a cool day
Ken, did you ever think that you'd be on Bleacher Report smoking?
Nah, pshh
Or talking about weed?
I thank Al for this
You know, I think Al really took a big step
with, really, his movement as a whole
but you got to think he said that with David Stern
you know, the NBA commissioner
And now we're on Bleacher Report smoking a joint
How far do you think we are from the NBA allowing players
- I think— I think they—
- to smoke weed
I think they will allow CBD—cannabinoids
I think, within the next
three to five years, I think
Um, I think there's enough testing there
I think there's enough people telling
you know, the right stories
I think the World Anti-Doping Agency
they just allowed, you know, CBDs in the Olympics
and different things like that
So I think some of those barriers are starting to
you know, be knocked down
But you know what's crazy?
It's not so much that— Not to cut you off, Al
but it's not so much the NBA says you can smoke weed now
It's that they don't test for it, you know what I mean?
We're the only major sport that gets
four random tests for this
- Only sports
- Baseball players
- Football gets one in the preseason
and they're tested for steroids
Baseball, same thing
Baseball don't even get tested for it
- Yeah
- No street drugs
Right, so it's just like, you know—
Like I say, it's a stereotype drug
it's a "black athlete"
- stereotype drug
- Yeah, historically the NBA's been
Right
We are the only
league that they test four times random for weed
Like, why?
You're not testing for alcohol
You're not testing for these— you know
I mean, these pills that are destroying our insides
that our trainers are giving us
- Right
- You know what I mean?
You're testing for weed 'cause you know we like to do it
For us, this is—
Our fraternity is our family
For this right here
it does so many different things for us
to calm us down
- Like you said too, and I mean
most guys that I, that I could think of
all of my teammates that smoked
they were always the ones that was always
like, in the house
- But chillin'
- Right
- Chillin'. Always in the house
They weren't out like, you know, on the city
like, "All right, yo, I'm gonna eat this dinner"
"I'm gonna be right here"
I'm curious for your two perspectives, though
because obviously you guys have investments
within the marijuana organizations and companies
in terms of what you guys are building
You guys concerned about the label
of like, drug dealer?
And how hard was that to kind of
like to box out as you guys were—
Understand, this was a business?
Like Al, I'm a— I'm a serial
you know, entrepreneur, and like
I just like to jump off the cliff
as long as I understand what I'm doing, right?
Like, it's not like we used to—
Like drug deals around the way
It's not like that
But you're building a foundation
Right?
For me that made me feel better
becasue now
I found my niche
Not so much medical marijuana
but just being a businessman
and learning a lot of things
I always believe that when someone tells you something
research it as much as you can
You never know that that can be your
you know
light at the end of the tunnel
So that's the only reason I went for it
I don't know. For me, I've never been
like, shy about it
You know what I mean?
Like, if somebody asks me what I'm working on
or what I got going on
I would always mention it
So for me, I haven't—
you know, I haven't met much resistance
How I got in, you know
I was in— I was in Denver
You know what I mean?
Um, my grandmother had come to see me
Uh, she, uh
She was 81 years old at the time
and she had, like, uh
set up all of her medication
like in the kitchen
There were, like, 30 different pills or whatever
so I'm like, "Damn, Grandma, you take all that every day?"
and she's like, "Yeah, I take it for this, that, glaucoma"
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah
She said glaucoma
I was like, "Damn, I just read something about glaucoma the other day"
So I'm telling her
I'm like, "Well, Grandma, you know, you should actually try it
and just see what happens"
So like I said, I'm from Jersey
where like, you know
growing up, anybody that smoked weed had no future
Like, nobody
You had like—
- Philly, everywhere
You had no chance at making it in life
You know, people just viewed you as, like
"He's done. Just write him off."
You know what I'm saying?
So, you know—
So I'm sitting here like, "Grandma, you should try it"
She's like, "Boy—"
No, first I told her, "You should try—"
I called it, uh
cannabis
And she's like, "What's that?"
And I was like, "Weed"
She's like, "Reefer?
I ain't smoking no reefer
Boy, you better get out of my face
I ain't smoking no reefer"
She's like, "Reefer messed up your uncle's life
and your grandfather's life
All these n---- weren't nothing
'cause of this reefer"
- Right
- Reefer
- So, reefer. So I'm like
"Grandma, look
why don't you just try the weed"
You know what I'm saying?
I was like, "Because they said it'll help"
And I was, like—
I was like, "The medicine you take is not working
Might as well give it a shot"
After a while, she was just like
"My eyes hurt so bad today
I'll try anything"
So I called my boy
He went, got her some Vietnam Kush, came back
He brought his volcano
Remember, I told you I ain't have none of this s--t
I just had it whenever I was with the homies
So he came, brought his volcano
He vaporized it, and we took her in the garage
She started hitting it, right?
So what's funny about that
she's smoking it, and she's like—
[nonchalant inhale]
[relaxed exhale]
and I'm looking like
"Damn, Grandma, are you sure you don't smoke?"
[laughter]
She says—
She's just—
- I'm like, "Damn"
- She knows what's going on here
- Like a pro
- She's like, "Boy, no, I ain't smoked"
blah, blah, blah
She's like, "I smoked cigarettes one time when I was 16"
So what else? So we take—
I take her downstairs. I take my nap
So when I wake up from my nap
I was getting ready to jump in the shower
and I said, "Let me just go check on her real quick"
Know what I'm saying?
Make sure she ain't down there bugging out or nothing
So I go downstairs
and I knock on the door
and her back is to the door
and she looking down
So I stick my head in
and I'm like, "Grandma, you all right?"
And she turned around, and she started crying
She's crying tears
and she's like, "I'm healed"
She's like, "You know, I haven't been able to read
the words in my Bible in over three years?"
And like, she crying
She made me start crying
And, like
after that it just completely changed
you know, my perception
Really, like, at this point it went from
just being a social thing that just made me feel good
to where I've seen, like, wow
all that s--t I been reading in the paper
is actually true
What is the perception you want, like
our B/R audience to understand
from this conversation about
athletes—and particularly in the NBA—and marijuana?
You can still be a successful person
successful athlete
Um, like, it doesn't make you a bad person
if you, um, consume cannabis
It doesn't make you a bad person
if you still functioning
and taking care of responsibilities and—
and doing all that
I mean, you can still be successful at what you're doing
You can't fight the science of it
You know, so you do your homework
and don't be naive to the fact that it's—
I'm saying it's helping people
We're actually trying to help
You know what I'm saying? We're—
We're trying to heal the world essentially
It's not about just
the monetary gains that we can get from this
You know what I'm saying? I really want to
be able to change people's lives
We're thinking legacy now
You know what I'm saying?
I met with some of the, um
people from the NBPA
during All-Star Week
you know, in February
And—
You know, I was telling all of them
I said, "That first chapter I wrote
is nothing compared to this second one I'm about to do"